I think that this movie for me really is
one of the greatest films for that very
reason and for the for the for the fact
that they put down as an historical
record the nature of the horror of
Nazism because when you get to that
moment in this movie when Tracy renders
the verdict and gives that great great
monologue the the film best bubbles with
great performances I mean there's
there's there's a shell who as the the
sympathetic Nazi defense attorney I mean
who could possibly bring the bravery and
the intelligence and the passion that
she'll brought he won the Oscar for the
film and she'll is just mesmerizing the
Widmark is a good job a couple of film
actors in the film and very very
peculiar times of their lives Clift
post-accident
garland very debilitated and fragile but
in the end the film builds of Marlena
Dietrich and those wonderful kind of pas
de deux she does with with with Tracy
but in the end it's Tracy giving that
speech which really distilled it's it's
a great actor working with a great
director working with a great
cinematographer for someone to deliver
the message of this film when Tracy has
that towering speech in which he says if
these were ordinary men and these are
these of these events would have no more
significance than any other act of God
or of nature he said but the fact that
the leadership of the Nazi Party were
extraordinary men who committed these
acts that's what makes it all the more
horrifying and when Tracy delivers that
speech I mean it still brings tears to
your eyes